on november 8th the u.s opened to
international travelers for the first
time since march 2020.
vaccinations approved by the world
health organization will be required for
all foreign travelers into the u.s with
people under 18 years old being exempt
and all incoming foreign visitors and
returning vaccinated us residents must
have a negative result from a covet test
taken within 72 hours before arriving in
the u.s unvaccinated american travelers
must be tested within 24 hours of
arrival
most countries that have opened their
borders have developed national digital
solutions for travelers to provide their
vaccine and testing information but the
us is putting the onus recovered
credential vetting on airlines that
means travelers coming to the us will
submit covert related documentation not
to customs and border protection but to
their airline these changes could cause
big delays for travelers according to
industry insiders the international air
transportation association said
travelers should be prepared for wait
times up to eight hours
that group says that number assumes
travel will return to pre-pandemic
numbers and the fact that the processing
time per passenger has gone from one to
two minutes to 16 minutes or more
it remains to be seen whether the united
states government will assume
responsibility for verifying coped
vaccination and testing credentials but
industry experts think they should a
comparative example close to home is
canada anyone entering canada has to
download the country's arrive can app
travelers upload their passport
information and covet documentation
before arriving at the airport and other
points of entry so they know in advance
whether they have the necessary
credentials to get a green light to
enter international travel returns at
the same time that airlines are gearing
up for a busy travel season in november
aaa estimated that 4.2 million americans
will travel by air between wednesday
november 24th and sunday november 28th
that's down 11 from the number of air
travelers in 2019 when 4.6 million
americans flew over the thanksgiving
holiday period
[Music]